[оплески]
Ласкаво просимо на іспит на громадянство
будь ласка сідайте як побажати успіху
німецькою мовою А точно речел я тримаю
за тебе
кулачки питання номер один які цінності
повинен сповідувати кожен німець ти
повинен постійно бурчати
ти повинен бути вкрай
чесним ти повинен регулярно провітрювати
[музика]
кімнату питання номер два у вас попереду
типові німецькі вихідні по-перше
сніданок що з цього не повинно бути на
столі сир м'ясна нарізка
тости ні так не піде набагато краще
свіжі булочки масло джем кава мюслі
йогурт смажені
боби яйця чай з
молоком вони не уявляють що втрачають що
ви повинні робити о 20:15 у неділю о
добре що я це вивчила щонеділі О 20:1 я
всідатимусь перед телевізором щоб
подивитися культовий німецький серіал
Місце
злочину Як думаєте вони здогадалися що
він мені не подобається наступне
запитання Уявіть ви підходите до
перехрестя світлофор червоний круги
жодної машини Як ви вчините А передете
дорогу або б почекаєте зеленого світла
цієї помилки я вже пропускалася мене
навіть зловила поліція та виписала штраф
кожен справжній німець знає не можна
нехтувати червоним світлом тепер час
перевірити вашу фізичну підготовку Ох
цей легендарний тест у німецькому
супермаркеті Отже жодних балачок з
касиром нормального місця скласти
продукти немає а люди у черзі позаду вас
будуть обурюватися головне тут швидкість
на старт увага
[оплески]
руш Гарного дня Дякую вам
теж І останнє запитання перегорніть
сторінку і витріщайтеся на неї більше
хвилини і не
плакати
що це за неправильно позначені відповіді
будуть зняті бали німці не ставлять
галочки лише
хрестики коли будуть результати через 10
тижнів Я люблю німецьку
[музика]
бюрократію